what you need to know this morning
though one specific team
having one specific player at practice
that we never expected to see
in a football uniform again one of the
greatest stories in the 101 year history
of the national football league
alex smith there's his family spraying
him with some sort of bubbly beverage
he is cleared to practice nearly two
years after
he almost lost his leg he almost lost
his life
compound fracture the bone comes out of
the skin all the bacteria from the skin
gets inside the body it was a horrible
infection
he had an external fixator on after they
almost amputated his leg
the the slow process
of getting himself back to this point
and the determination to get here
it would have been very easy chris for
him to just say oh hey i'm 35 36 years
old i've played my
football i'm not going back out there
and breaking my leg again i'm done
it's amazing to me what he has overcome
the hurdles the adversity the obstacles
the serious life and death situation to
get back to this point
that gives me chills and he hasn't even
won a roster spot yet although with a 17
million dollar guaranteed salary
i think he will the question is can he
win the starting job
and i feel bad for dwayne haskins
because i don't think there's a person
in the country other than a family
member of dwayne haskins that's rooting
for him to win it and even then they
probably wouldn't be all that upset
if alex smith ends up being the starter
in washington well it is like the
ultimate feel-good story i mean
it's unbelievable where we are i mean
you know i don't know a year ago i i
wrote him off i just thought hey
it's over you know i'm hoping he gets
healthy i just hope he can walk around
and be a good dad and enjoy life
that's really where i was at i didn't
even like get the inkling that
uh this was going to happen and and you
know you talk about the slow process
mike it's it's something i can
you know put my my you know feet in his
shoes a little bit after losing my
spleen
you know it is a sole process you know
you kind of broke it down the right way
you go through it going
okay let me just you know make it
through surgery so they can piece my leg
together
okay um let me just see if i can just
start feeling normal and like you know
eat some food after surgery and hop
around the house
and now you have an infection now you're
going into oh oh my gosh okay i hope i
can just survive and live and then it
goes into
you know all right i just i hope i can
get better to where i can walk around
one day and be a good dad
and do those things and then all of a
sudden you're working out and then
you're going oh it feels pretty good
and you start to get more and more
intense as you go through the process of
working out you start to get little
crazy thoughts in your head like huh
you know i feel pretty good i think i
might be able to play football again
i could do this and you you this is what
football players do
so i'm not shocked because i think alex
smith is a lifer
like he's a guy that brings it home it's
part of his life it always has been
and uh it's amazing that he is where he
is right now and
yeah it's it adds a little interesting
wrinkle to
the whole washington quarterback debate
they got a top 20 pick they'd like to
go into the future with but alex smith
you know he's kind of saying wait wait
i don't want the future to be here quite
yet i got something to bring to the
table
and i just i i i'm interested to see
you know how how live is he how how
can he hop around that pocket like we
talked about it'd just be interesting to
gauge from here on out and see where it
goes
and chris we got some mixed signals a
couple of weeks ago because alex smith
told espn he was cleared for all
football activities and then
the team put him on the physically
unable to perform list which meant he
couldn't pass a physical
but i think that what they were trying
to do and quarterback's coach ken
zampesi explained this to reporters
a couple of weeks ago they wanted to
monitor him they wanted to watch him
they wanted to be sure he can protect
himself
even with the jersey on that says don't
touch me in practice it's still
not a completely risk-free scenario
because you could accidentally get hit
you've got bodies all around you
they wanted to be able to monitor
whether or not he could still move like
he needed to move
that he could protect himself when he
needs to protect himself
before they put him on the active roster
so
this is the significance of him making
it from the pup list
to the full roster they've determined he
can do those things
they've come to that preconclusion he's
going to be fine
we're going to put him out there into
the fray with everyone else and that's
what's so exciting about this because
now
as the pads come on the competition
begins between dwayne haskins
and alex smith and look chris if he can
play like he did
up until the point where he suffered the
broken leg he can win the starting job
this isn't a situation where it's like
competing with a journeyman
who's just there as a placeholder this
is dwayne haskins the top 15 pick
competing with a top half of the nfl
quarterback before he suffered the
injury
that they just assumed would never play
again it's the ultimate good problem to
have
and now you just let the two i i hope
and i think and i trust that ron rivera
will do this
we'll just go out and let them compete
and the better
man will be the starter week one and
it'll be a fair competition not about
well we have to get the most out of
dwayne haskins he was a top 15 pick no
whoever is better should be the one who
starts week one well yeah i mean i
agree with you i'm not necessarily sure
that'll be the reality of the situation
you know because i do think that dwayne
haskins will be favored in this right
where okay yeah we want him to compete
you know head to head
and and really have no bias that way but
it's hard to erase the bias of ooh
this top 20 pick thing like you just
talked about and
to also see maybe the bigger picture a
little bit
and the potential down the road and what
the team could be
so that's where you know i i agree with
you i think they are going to compete
all i'm trying to say to what you said
is just that i think if alex smith maybe
just
barely beats dwayne haskins in the
competition they're gonna go with dwayne
haskins
if alex smith like convincingly
has a bunch of days where they go whoa
okay he made some good throws and dwayne
haskins is making some
you know bad decisions interceptions
things like that
and he and alex smith there's a number
of days where he really
let's say kick dwayne haskins butt for
lack of a better phrase as far as the
competition
aspects concerned then i think you see
alex smith but i think it's like it's
one of those things where i go the tie
the tie goes to the runner the tie goes
to the first round pick or the young guy
here
uh but nonetheless i think alex smith
will have a legit chance i i can't
i i wouldn't expect ron rivera and
company to not let it be that way really
but that there are factors chris that i
think cut against the normal bias that
would favor the top 15 pick
for example yeah ron rivera wasn't there
when dwayne haskins was drafted
there's no one really in the
organization other than doug williams at
a high level
that that has any ownership of that pick
and you look at it look alex smith is
making 17 million this year right he is
higher paid for this season
than dwayne haskins is and on top of it
the last time a young quarterback
sat and watched alex smith for a full
year
yeah it worked out it worked out pretty
well worked out very well right
it worked it worked out pretty well for
patrick mahomes to sit and watch and
learn from alex smith especially because
here's the thing alex smith is a unicorn
in a sense that he's not going to be
territorial he's not going to be a jerk
he's not going to be standoffish he's
going to do everything he can
and i think last year he did everything
he could to help the young guys learn
how to play even if it means he teaches
them so well he's looking for another
team next year because that's precisely
what he did with the chiefs well yes i
mean i agree with you he is going to be
the perfect soldier
for your football team no matter what
whether he's the starter
or yeah he's the backup for dwayne
haskins if he is that if it does come to
that
he will be you know the ultimate role
model teach him how to be a pro
how to practice do all of those things
but i think like
you know philosophical wise right like
it
it's it brings up a good question here
about where you want to go with this
washington football team
you know what do you what do you want to
do i think that's a real question here
you know of course they haven't seen
enough of dwayne haskins yet to really
go
like oh i see this and i see that
let's just go with them you know they're
still in probably the early phases of
really trying to evaluate the player and
the human being still
you know what alex smith is certainly
but i
you know mike do you want to start the
new era
right now you know with terry mccoy and
dwayne hask and some of these other
young weapons on offense
or yeah do you want to you know maybe
not be as dangerous on offense but
certainly with a guy who knows how to
run the game and and do all those things
and maybe you win an extra game or two
because
he understands you know how to play the
position a little bit better
uh that's that's a big question i mean
it really is i i don't know what the
answer is to that
i would tend to go with the young guy as
close like i said
to build something for the future but i
can understand you know going the other
way with alex smith
here's the other thing too we talked
about this previously the fact that
haskins played a lot last year makes it
harder to put him on the bench it does
but
if he can't deal with that that's one of
the factors that tells you whether or
not you truly have a long-term franchise
quarterback if he can deal with taking a
back seat
to alex smith and if he embraces every
opportunity he has to learn from alex
smith and if he does learn from alex
smith
you have a better finished product in
the end and i almost compare it to
and let's just set aside last year let's
treat dwayne haskins like he's a rookie
and
as far as ron rivera is concerned he is
it's easier to start with alex smith
and then turn the page to dwayne haskins
to do it the other way around
if you go with haskins and you say well
you know what it's really not working
our better chance of winning we think
comes from alex smith
then you make it even harder for dwayne
haskins down the road i
and look i i just wanted to be a fair
competition whoever the better man
is should play and if it is close it's
going to be a hell of a decision for ron
rivera to make because there is going to
be
a strong degree of sentimentality
there's going to be a greater degree of
interest that they are going to be
viewed as a more sympathetic team at a
time when they can use
that if alex smith is the quarterback
chris yeah well that's that's a good
point i mean
certainly i never thought of it that way
um
but also dwayne haskins brings
excitement to the franchise and stuff
like that too where i think people want
to see you know that top 20 pick
right i mean few aspects i think jump
out to me
too you know scott turner new offensive
coordinator there right i mean he runs
his father's offense norv turner's
offense
you know it is more of a an aggressive
push the ball
down the field type of offense that i do
think
suits maybe a dwayne haskins more than
alex smith
you know i mean the reason hey versus
you know like we've talked about before
the reason alex smith isn't in kansas
city anymore is because he was unwilling
to push the ball down the field and be
aggressive and make plays
you know that's really what it was he
was the number one rated quarterback in
football when they decided to make a
change
that just tells you that that team
thought ah there was more there to be
had even though you're still the number
one rated quarterback
we believe there was more so and you
know
just to throw that throw this in you
know we always act like well it always
worked out for mahomes he had a pretty
good
right and i know it did it did but who's
to say he wouldn't have thrown for 40
touchdowns as a rookie and and eight
interceptions
oh you know that's i'm just throwing it
out hey
chris chris you may remember this i sat
in this chair in the 2017 season when
they were
struggling in kansas city yeah and the
offense was sputtering
saying put my homes in put my homes and
put my homes in
so and and here's the other thing too i
think that it wasn't so much
they thought they were they had gotten
as far as they were ever going to get
with alex smith
brett veach discovered patrick mahomes
sure and sold andy reed on patrick
mahomes
and the organization realized you know
hey we have a guy here that's going to
be a generational talent
that is going to be our starter well
into the future that he's going to bring
a super bowl to town and also farther
right in just his second season as a
starter
so i don't think it's an indictment of
alex smith the question is how does
washington feel about
haskins yeah in relation to smith and
that's all that's what we don't know
it's we don't know and that's going to
be part of the fun over the next four
weeks and beyond already joe theismann
who went through the same kind of injury
that alex smith did in the 80s and
didn't come back
theismann told espn over the weekend
that alex smith is already
the nfl's comeback player of the year
for 2020. draftkings has
alex smith and big ben ben rothersberger
the steelers quarterback tied
for comeback player of the year odds
with the lowest at plus
300. i think that i think alex smith
still has to play i don't think it's
enough
to be able just to get back on a roster
and be the backup i think he still needs
to play
but i don't think he needs to play very
much to clinch this award for 2020. the
mere fact
that that he's able to play is stunning
and makes him one of the all-time great
comeback stories in nfl history
yeah agreed i mean yeah i'm with you in
the camp of like you got to play
right i mean as awesome as the story is
and certainly not trying to like
de-legitimize it or anything like that
like yeah it's amazing but yeah for the
spirit of the rule
yeah it's about being back on the field
and coming back and you know
contributing to your team that way
and we got some good candidates i mean
there's no doubt i mean between alex
smith big ben and
and even gronk down in tampa holy cow
that's a
you know a star-studded name how about
bradley chubb in denver
i mean here's another guy who is you
know a stud who missed last year
but it's amazing we're even having this
conversation
just to go back to that because i mean
really where does it rank in your
all-time ranking
for me joe theismann will always be
number one the most gruesome injury i've
ever seen
you know there was that napoleon
mccallum injury right the raiders
fullback
with ken norton jr on his leg in that
monday night game a long time ago
and then there's alex smith and maybe
tim crumry in the super bowl the bengals
you know 49ers but i mean it is
no doubt in the conversation for one of
the most gruesome
gross injuries i have ever seen and
i just say way to go alex smith to come
back from that you the man and
just tells you what kind of guy he is in
general
yeah one of the one of the most gruesome
injuries we've seen in one of the best
comeback stories we've seen
next hour we will be drafting the
all-time best nfl individual comeback
stories
we may exempt alex smith from that one
because there are plenty of others one
thing i learned while thinking about it
brainstorming and researching there have
been plenty of great comeback stories
but
if alex smith comes back wins the
starting job plays most of the season
you can argue there's been none greater
in the history of the national football
league than what alex smith has done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports